ED?
>> Ed: ALL RIGHT, CHRISTINA
COLEMAN THANK YOU FOR THAT
REPORT.
THE IMPACT OF THE OUTBREAK CAN
ALSO BE FELT ON CAPITOL HILL.
GEORGIA CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS
IS ONE OF SEVERAL REPUBLICANS
WHO DECIDED TO SELF-QUARANTINE
AFTER COMING IN CONTACT WITH
AFFECTEDINFECTED PERSON AT CPAC.
>>
>> Sandra: SENATE CANDIDATE DOUG
COLLINS, APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING.
APPRECIATE YOU SKYPING IN
CONSIDERING YOU ARE STAYING IN.
WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO DO THAT?
>> WE DID SO OUT OF AN ABUNDANCE
OF CAUTION.
GOOD TO SEE YOU THOUGH.
BECAUSE WE CAME IN CONTACT.
IT’S BEEN TWO WEEKS AGO TODAY.
IN FACT TODAY IS MY LAST DAY.
I WILL BE BACK OUT TOMORROW.
I’M A SYMPTOMATIC.
I HAVE NEVER HAD ANY SYMPTOMS OF
THE VIRUS.
MAKE SURE OUT OF AN ABUNDANCE OF
CAUTION STAY IN AND EMPHASIZE TO
EVERYONE THAT IF THEY FOLLOW THE
RULES, THEY FOLLOW THE PROTOCOLS
THAT ARE SET OUT, THAT WE CAN
MANAGE THIS VIRUS AND WE CAN DO
WHAT IS RIGHT.
I THINK BY DOING THIS, WE ARE
SETTING EXAMPLE TO OTHERS DON’T
TAKE IT LIGHTLY, TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY, BUT ALSO DON’T PANIC.
MAKE SURE YOU ARE DOING THE
RIGHT THINGS, WASHING YOUR
HANDS, STAYING AWAY IF YOU ARE
SICK.
IF YOU ARE SICK, GO TO THE
DOCTOR AND GET TESTED.
>> Ed: VERY IMPORTANT ADVICE AND
CERTAINLY CONCERNED ABOUT YOUR
HEALTH AND ALL LAWMAKERS, STAFF,
AND EVERYONE AROUND THE COUNTRY.
OBVIOUSLY.
THIS IS ALSO HAPPENING IN A
CONTEXT WHERE IN THE LAST MOMENT
WE HAVE JUST GOTTEN A NEW
STATEMENT FROM SENATOR TED CRUZ.
HE HAS ALSO BEEN
SELF-QUARANTINED AS YOU KNOW I
BELIEVE IN TEXAS.
HE IS SAYING THAT HIS D.C.
OFFICE IS GOING TO CLOSE
TEMPORARILY.
SENATOR ROMNEY HAS DONE THE
SAME.
AT LEAST ONE CASE OF SOMEBODY
WHO HAS TESTED POSITIVE FOR
CORONAVIRUS IN THE OFFICE OF
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR MARIA
CANTWELL.
SO IT’S HAPPENING IN THAT
CONTEXT, CONGRESSMAN WHILE WALL
STREET IS ALSO SUFFERING A VERY
VOLATILE DAY RIGHT NOW.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
COUNTRY ARE LOOKING TO YOU AND
OTHER LAWMAKERS TO GET THE
NATION’S BUSINESS DONE.
AND WORKING ON AN ECONOMIC
PROPOSAL THAT THE PRESIDENT
WANTS.
HOW DO YOU BALANCE ALL OF THAT,
SIR?
>> WELL, IT’S BEEN A LARGE
BALANCE.
I THINK I HAVE BEEN AT WORK ALL
WEEK DOWN HERE.
WE HAVE OTHER BILLS ON THE FLOOR
THIS WEEK.
FISA BILLS AND ALSO NOW WORKING
I WAS JUST ON A CONFERENCE CALL
WITH MY COLLEAGUES CONCERNING
OUR RESPONSE.
LOOK, I THINK YOU WILL SEE A LOT
OF OTHER OFFICES, ESPECIALLY
NEXT WEEK.
WE ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE IN
YOU WILL SEE PROBABLY A LOT OF
WORKING FROM HOME, PROBABLY AND
WE ARE DISCUSSING THAT RIGHT NOW
IN MY OWN OFFICE AND MAKING SURE
OUR D.C. OFFICE.
YOU WILL SEE IT.
WE ARE ALREADY STARTING TO SEE A
COUPLE CASES NOW ON STAFF ON THE
SENATE SIDE AND OTHERS.
SO IT IS A VERY REAL CONCERN.
WE WANT TO STOP IT IN ITS
TRACKS.
THIS IS WHY THE PROTOCOLS ARE IN
PLACE SO WE CAN IDENTIFY THAT
ARE SICK.
ISOLATE THEM, GET THEM BETTER SO
THAT OTHERS AREN’T INFECTED.
IN DEALING ALSO WITH THIS
ECONOMIC SIDE.
THE PRESIDENT MADE IT VERY CLEAR
LAST NIGHT THAT HE IS WILLING TO
HELP.
BUT HE WANTS TO HELP IN THE
PROPER WAY.
SIMPLY THROWING MONEY AT A
SITUATION RIGHT NOW WITHOUT
HAVING PROPER OVERSIGHT EVEN
DEMOCRATS LAST NIGHT IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT NO
HEARINGS OR ANYTHING INVOLVED IN
THIS.
WE WANT TO WORK BY PAR SANLY
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE
HAVE WHAT THEY NEED FROM
ECONOMIC STANDPOINT BUT MAKE
SURE IT’S TARGETED TO MAKE SURE
THE ECONOMIC STIMULUS OR
PROGRESS HERE IS NOT JUST SIMPLY
THROWING MONEY AT A PROBLEM
WITHOUT ANY REAL SOLUTIONS TO
MAKING THE ECONOMY OR HELPING
THOSE WHO NEED HELP.
>> Sandra: YOU CAN ASSUME THE
MARKET IS LOOKING FOR A
SOLUTION.
AS YOU HAVE BEEN SPEAKING THE
DOW IS OFF MORE THAN 2,000
REPORTS.
WE CAN NOW REPORT THAT THE DOW
HAS FALLEN TO LOWEST LEVEL SINCE
JULY 2017.
SO, LOOKING AT MULTI--YEAR LOWS
HERE.
AND I WILL LET YOU KNOW THAT OUR
REPORTING FROM CAPITOL HILL AS
OF THIS MOMENT IS THAT G.O.P.
LEADERS MCCARTHY AND MCCONNELL
OPPOSE HOUSE DEMOCRATS’
CORONAVIRUS BILL.
THE STATUS OF THE BILL IS NOW IN
LIMBO.
COM, HOW DO YOUCONGRESSMAN, HOW
>> I RESPOND IN UNISON WITH
LEADER MCCARTHY IN THIS AS WELL
AND MITCH MCCONNELL.
AGAIN, WE NEED A STIMULUS
PACKAGE.
WE ALSO NEED SOMETHING THAT
ACTUALLY WILL WORK.
THERE IS NOTHING THAT WE HAVE
SEEN SO FAR THAT ACTUALLY STEMS
THIS TIDE.
SIMPLY PUTTING MONEY INTO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WHETHER
YOU HAVE UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS AT
THEIR LOWEST.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT YOU WORK
ON AS THE SITUATION DEVELOPS.
WE NEED A STIMULUS NOW THAT IF
IT HELPS SMALL BUSINESSES.
MAKE SURE YOU GET EXTENDED
LEAVE.
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF THINGS
WORK INTO THIS BILL.
RIGHT NOW NOT BEEN ABLE TO
PARTNER LIKE WE DID WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS PACKAGE FROM LAST
WEEK IN WHICH WE PROVIDED FUNDS
FOR THE ACTUAL ATTACKING OF THE
VIRUS AND THE RESPONSE TO THAT
VIRUS.
THAT WAS BIPARTISAN, OVER 400
VOTES.
THERE IS NO REASON WHY WE CAN’T
DO THIS TODAY AND WORK ON THAT
AS WE GO FORWARD AND I KNOW OUR
LEADER MCCARTHY AND OTHERS HAS
TALKED TO US AND KEVIN BRADY AND
OTHERS TALKED TO US ON THE
CONFERENCE CALL ABOUT WHY THIS
IS NOT A PACKAGE THAT AT THIS
POINT WE CAN SUPPORT BUT I KNOW
THE PRESIDENT IS COMMITTED TO
FINDING SOMETHING THAT IS
POSSIBLY GOING TO WORK AND OUR
LEADERSHIP IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE DEMOCRAT
LEADERSHIP TO FIND THAT.
MARKETS WILL BE AWARE OF THAT.
I THINK WE JUST NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A FOCUSED
RESPONSE AND I BELIEVE THAT’S
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
GETTING.
>> Ed: CONGRESSMAN, IN FACT, YOU
JUST MENTIONED THE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN LEADER KEVIN
MCCARTHY, WE EXPECT HIM TO HOLD
A NEWS CONFERENCE LIVE IN THE
NEXT FEW MOMENTS.
WE WILL GO THERE LIVE TO SEE
WHAT HE IS SAYING ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC PLANS AND RESPONSE AS
WELL.
NANCY PELOSI EXPECTED TO HAVE A
NEWS CONFERENCE.
WE WILL GO THREURT THERE LATER
IN THE HOUR AND HEAR FROM BOTH
SIDES.
YOU ARE LAYING OUT THE IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC RESPONSE AND WHAT YOU
WANT TO SEE HAPPEN.
WHAT ABOUT THE HEALTH RESPONSE?
ABOUT A WEEK AGO YOU WERE WITH
THE PRESIDENT IN YOUR HOME STATE
THERE IN GEORGIA AT THE CDC
HEADQUARTERS AND WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT THEY ARE PREPARED ON
TESTING AND THAT IF YOU WANT TO
BE TESTED YOU CAN BE TESTED FOR
THE CORONAVIRUS BUT, A FEW
MOMENTS AGO SANDRA INTERVIEWED
REPUBLICAN SENATOR JOHN
BARRASSO, WHO, AS YOU KNOW, IS
NOT JUST A SENATOR, HE’S A
DOCTOR.
HE SAYS HE STILL HAS CONCERNS
THAT THE CDC CAN REALLY FOLLOW
THROUGH ON THAT.
WHAT ASSURANCES CAN YOU GIVE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THIS MORNING?
>>
>> THE A SURANCE I HAVE STRAIGHT
FROM THE CDC AND WORKING AND
LISTENING TO NOT THE PRESIDENT
BUT THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
TASK FORCE AND CDC OF COURSE IN
MY HOME STATE, WE NEVER FORGET
THIS IS THE GROUP THAT ALSO JUST
A FEW YEARS AGO WAS ABLE TO GET
UNDER CONTROL THE EBOLA VIRUS
AND OTHERS.
THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACCUSTOMED TO DEALING WITH HARD
ISSUES.
AND THEY ARE DEALING WITH IT.
THE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE NOW IS
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
TESTING IS THERE FOR THOSE THAT
ARE SICK.
WHAT WE DON’T NEED TO HAVE IS
RUSHING OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
AND RUSHING OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM WITH FOLKS THAT ARE JUST
WONDERING IF THEY HAVE THE
VIRUS.
IF YOU ARE SICK, YOU HAVE
CONDITIONS, FLU LIKE CONDITIONS,
SYMPTOMS, THEN GO GET TESTED.
BUT I THINK RIGHT NOW THE
TESTING AS IT IS RAMPING UP, THE
MORE TEST KITS THAT R. A
AVAILABLE WE WILL MAKE SURE
ANYONE THAT HAS THOSE SYMPTOMS
ARE ABLE TO BE TESTED.
I TRUST THE CDC.
IT’S ALWAYS AS WE LOOK FORWARD
THOUGH WE MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
HAPPENING IN REALTIME.
THEY ARE PUTTING FORWARD THE
RESULTS.
THINK WE WILL SEE OVER TIME AS
THAT WORKS OUT.
RIGHT NOW I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE THAT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND EVERY STATE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING THEY POSSIBLY
CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
IDENTIFY THE PROPER CASES.
MAKE SURE THAT THEY’RE PROPERLY
QUARANTINED.
MAKE SURE THEY ARE PROPERLY
BEING TREATED.
THERAPEUTICS BEING DEVELOPED
LONG TERM VACCINE DEVELOPED AS
WELL.
BE SURE NOT TO PANIC AND DOING
WHAT IS RESPONSIBLE.
ONE OF THE THINGS I HAVE TOLD
PEOPLE FOR THE WHOLE WEEK THAT I
HAVE BEEN HERE.
SO SIMPLEST THINGS ARE SOMETIMES
THAT YOU FORGET WHEN YOU BELIEVE
BIG CRISIS.
THIS GOES BACK TO SIMPLE BASIC
PERSONAL HIGH SKWRAOEFPBLT GO
BACK TO THE SINK, USE SOAP, WASH
YOUR HANDS.
D.O. DON’T GO OUT COUGHING
PEOPLE.
IF YOU ARE SICK STAY AWAY.
IF YOU ARE SICK, MAKE SURE YOU
ARE TREATED.
THOSE ARE THE WAYS MAKE SURE TO
ISOLATE, THIS STOP IT.
IT WILL CONTINUE TO GROW, BUT WE
CAN DO SO AT A MUCH LOWER PACE
THAN WE HAVE SEEN IN THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
>> Sandra: LEARNING A LOT MORE
ABOUT THE SPREAD OF IT AND HOW
LONG IT CAN LIVE IN THE AIR.
THINGS WE DIDN’T EVEN KNOW
YESTERDAY OR A WEEK AGO.
SO, CONGRESSMAN, THERE IS STILL
A LOT TO TAKE IN, AS YOU CAN SEE
MARKETS TAKING ALL OF THIS IN
THIS MORNING.
WE WISH YOU WELL AS YOU FINISH
OFF YOUR SELF-QUARANTINE THERE
AND TED CRUZ, I THINK, FINISHES
HIS THIS AFTERNOON WHILE HE IS
ALSO SHUTTING DOWN HIS OFFICE